the purge has evolved from a low-budget
home-invasion horror into a politically
charged survival franchise over the
course of its three installments so far
but before this vision of the dystopian
hellscape began to have such scary
similarities to current events there
were some real-life tragedies that
inspired the movie and some scary events
that followed the films as well to make
it a full-circle experience thank you
for your sacrifice here's the untold
truth of the purge wicked history the
first question on most people's minds
after watching a purge movie is what
would happen if they really did that and
the answer is well they kind of did
Roman pagans used to celebrate a
festival called Saturnalia which was a
week-long period of lawlessness that
allowed citizens to go crazy and get out
all their pent-up aggression without
fear of retribution
right before Christmas a Saturnalia
miracle of course there were winners and
losers in this open season approach to
crime and the whole purpose was to show
the masses what life would be like
without the rule of law but still those
Persians were crazy the aftermath
unfortunately if the real-life parallels
between the purge and society don't stop
there in May 2016
an Indiana teen was arrested for
kidnapping a woman at a fast food
restaurant and he was then connected to
a string of murders over a three-day
spree that he referred to as a nightly
purge mr. crews went on a four-day
one-man purge futile resistance when
writer director james demonaco first
came up with the idea for the purge he
decided to run it by his dad who just so
happened to remember something similar
happening on a Star Trek episode with a
similar premise in the original series
Kirk and Spock are tried to help a
planet whose people a dick
hated by an artificially intelligent
authoritarian computer system and the
shock to find out that every day at 6
p.m. the red hour of the computer shut
down and people were free to go nuts
with all of the wicked ways in
situations like this when that old
phrase comes in handy give me about
personal rage when he considered the
high levels of bloodshed needed to bring
his dark vision for America to the big
screen it might seem odd that demonaco
has a fear of firearms but the gun
violence that seems to grip the u.s.
every other week was actually one of the
reasons he wanted to make the purge
films the brooklyn-born filmmaker found
himself gripped by the news coverage
every time a story about a shooting was
on finally coming to the realization
that traditional villains have become
far less scary than the random man on
the street his firearm phobia wouldn't
begin to develop into an idea for a
feature film until he found himself in a
violent road rage incident demonaco
revealed that he once became involved in
a fight with another motorist after the
driver in question almost killed the
director and his wife while drunk behind
the wheel demonaco reportedly wrestled
the man to the ground while police were
on their way and something his wife said
after the fracas became the root of the
idea behind purging as a concept
demonaco recalled this guy had been
idiotic about the whole thing he was
being a real jerk and she was raging
we were both rage we were on fire and
then she turns to me and says wouldn't
it be great if we could have one free
one a year I knew exactly what she meant
and I said wow honey
that's a bold statement but it stayed
with me close call scenes still a Rhys
Wakefield was cast in the purge just one
day before shooting began his character
known as the polite leader was arguably
one of the most visually arresting
aspects of the movie but it was a happy
accident that the right guy got the role
the Australian actor was chosen for the
part during an all-night casting call
held out of desperation the night before
production launched and luckily
Wakefield sly confidence was just the
right level of creepy to match the role
of leading a group that was inspired by
demonic oohs fascination with the Manson
Family murderous wedded bliss Shane and
Liz from the purge Aniki are actually
married in real life the actors Zac
Guildford and Keely Sanchez auditioned
to star as the on-screen couple and
boasted an authentic built-in connection
based on their real-life relationship
they'd been together since 2010 when
they met on the set of a failed TV pilot
and had been together for four years
before sharing the screen again in the
second purge flick Trump dumps the third
installment to the franchise 2016's the
purge election year took a different
approach keeping the traditional horror
elements but blending in some political
thriller aspects according to de Monaco
the plot was inspired by the 2016 race
for the White House if not directly then
certainly subconsciously demonaco
admitted that drips of what was
happening in the debates made it through
to him as he was penning the screenplay
though he refused to say which
characters represent which real-life
politicians in some cases it was pretty
obvious
next up the purge 3 was originally
expected to arrive as a prequel and go
back to the night of the first purge to
explain the origins of the new founding
fathers and now that a fourth film is
underway that's the direction the next
instalment may take as the monokote old
cinema blend I would actually go back
and would try to talk about how it all
started that seems the natural next
chapter in this is the save alright
we've done this trilogy we see how it
got to this point of someone trying to
end it this presidential figure now
let's go back and see how all this came
about how did this country get to a
place where we were now accepting this
kind of atrocity this terrible thing
each year I think there's something
interesting in that there's also a purge
TV show on the way which will showcase
the gore and grit of different purged
night experiences and what drives
ordinary people to get to the point of
participating in such murder and mayhem
in the first place you know aside from
those ridiculous commercials I purged
because Damon is an American don't let
your freedoms get taken away hey maybe
it'll be a good cautionary tale for
current times thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]